à l'occasion de la journée mondiale des
océans navigon au coeur du pacifique
avec le film vaiana la légende du bout
du monde à la rencontre de l'association
te mana o te moana à tahiti comme vaiana
et cerise l'association soigne les
tortures découvrez l'histoire de weihan
haïti une jeune tortue verte recueillies
sur un site de ponte de l'atoll de
tetiaroa après avoir été soigné pendant
plusieurs mois elle est maintenant apte
à rejoindre son milieu naturel en toute
sécurité
ensemble protégeons les océans vaiana la
légende du bout du monde avec vous
partout en blu ray 3d blu ray dvd vidéo
à la demande et achats digital
non
[Musique]